dude they're twins
[Music]
we're Griffins at two wow these guys are
ill as [ __ ] hey I'm into this oh there's
three third one
yeah here's my thing the guy that sent
in this video
wouldn't say this to these guys
but also your move listen how about the
dude that's [ __ ] trailing him in
front yeah filming just going backwards
like this dude hit it or he's just gotta
hit it yeah he's got a GoPro on his back
yeah there he's just following him yeah
all right well don't be I mean that to
hold that shot no way no GoPro has the
the wide yeah but you but you think he's
getting that good just doing that I
basically like going backwards
he's doing it like he's like this he's
going like this giving the stable it's a
good bro I bet you it's a ghost but he's
back dude you know you can skate
backwards dude I know but you can get it
backwards and not you know I've been a
real listen those guys are [ __ ] high
so we're more impressed with the dude
filming I am you know what it is the
guy's skating forward looking forward
he's got a little person on his back
just holding it foreign
just so much funnier dude but they're
not really doing anything good they're
just they're skating like I did in
middle school that's way honestly for a
white person that's way harder than what
those black guys are doing oh the one
guy in all black was kind of had some
rhythms yeah no but they're like they're
told hey hey don't black this up too
much the camera's on the camera's on you
chill out chill out afterwards that guy
got let off the company oh look at that
guy's outfit no that's a that's a field
trip for an old person so that's what
that is yeah an hour of well this is
them remembering back when we used to go
to skating rinks I used to love it Skate
City so the guy was asking a question
it's called skate jamming Jam skating
yeah that's what this is if the three of
us learn some moves and got it official
gotta take us into the next Stratosphere
of Fame I'll tell you that if we could
do that the new intro should be this is
what this
patreon should be is now we need to go
do this yeah uh you're giving us more
work to do yeah and injuries so Chris is
like Bambi he pulls his ham [ __ ]
running yeah you imagine Chris a big
stork I'm [ __ ] eyes
how ill would it look though if we were
all the same level of dancing my dancing
would be the illest even if we were all
the same talent-wise dancing
my [ __ ] would look to illness because of
how my body I think you look dance off
right now no no I know but we're not the
same level of time if we did this if we
had the same level of dancing Talent my
[ __ ] would look extra special
I mean it would dude here's my thing
though you didn't do it in pants if we
do the dance Escape you can do it in
shorts you can look like a flamingo out
there even better that would look hot
you know what I mean you know you look
like a [ __ ] you know you're built like a
flamingo right these are just knobby
yeah they're not knobby yeah I have
skinny legs but that won't go away worse
knees I don't accept that